[Music]
twitch
and drama go hand in hand every week on
this channel
we make videos covering some of the most
shocking and craziest scandals that
twitch spits out
from 25-page documents exposing
streamers
to behavior that really shouldn't have
been caught on camera
there have been some absolute bangers so
let's take a look
at the best of the best with the top 10
twitch
drama moments
starting off at number 10 we have fed
versus
pokemane where do we even start
with this one fred meister used to be a
member of offline tv
the popular streaming house that seemed
very happy from the outside
that all changed in june 2020 though
when fed was removed from the group
and left the house after two members
came forward with
sexual misconduct allegations against
him
this was backed up by one of the other
housemates pokemane who also accused fed
of being manipulative and trying to get
another housemate yvonne
kicked from the group and realized that
he would lie about me
a lot create create narratives in his
favor
and insinuate a lot of negative things
which drove
everyone around me away from me five
months later
a 25-page statement from fed was
leaked titled my truth in which he
addressed the allegations
he stated that it was actually pokey who
wanted yvonne kicked
and also shared screenshots as evidence
that there was
more to his and pokey's relationship
than she was letting on
pokemane eventually fired back with a
document of her own
and a video rebuttal to fed's original
statement
at the end of it all they both
apologized and pokemane seemed
especially keen to put the whole thing
behind her
but anyways looking back i should have
been more aware and careful of how i
acted around him so there are no signals
to misread but you know hindsight 20
and i learned a lot from the situation
to me
in all honesty it's really
all of this is really not all that
important
hey remember mixer let's dig that one
back up now for add number nine
in august 2019 ninja announced he was
leaving twitch to stream
exclusively on mixer microsoft's answer
to twitch
the deal was reportedly worth tens of
millions of dollars and for a while
it seemed to be paying off with mixers
slowly making
gains on its big rival then suddenly
everything changed mix is closing down
and they've it's not like they gave us
warning in june 2020
microsoft announced they pulled the plug
on mixer
sure the big names like ninja and shroud
were fine they had their money and could
even head back to twitch
but as the dust settled it was the
smaller streamers who took the biggest
hits
we'll chat we'll be moving somewhere
else
how am i gonna pay the bills
in my [ __ ] house
without being a partner
next up at number eight we have one of
twitch's most controversial names
destiny in january 2021 the twitch drama
world
exploded when destiny accused fellow
streamer bob
seven of sharing intimate photos of
women without their consent
and [ __ ] talking about him to people in
his life at some point like i go
upstairs into the hotel room
and there's like 10 girls on a
group call and they're all talking like
holy [ __ ] like bob seven is like said
all the same
to me in true twitch drama fashion bob7
then
shared a 39-page rebuttal
which also hit back at destiny accusing
him of manipulation and abuse
the origins of the drama stem back to
destiny's relationship
with another streamer melina the two had
an open relationship and at some point
molina had confided in bob
about her problems with the relationship
as the spat continued the tide
seemed to be turning against destiny in
his own live stream bob alleged that
some of the women that destiny
referenced
have been pressured to go along with his
narrative they went through great
efforts
to make sure i had no clue what i was
being accused of i can't stress
how [ __ ] up it was but that was like
what it was being done to these girls
one of my friends broke down crying to
me talking about how pressured she was
to go along with the narrative even
though she didn't think it was true fos
joked to this girl if you go along with
this we will all host you
this same girl could not stop crying
about the guilt of feeling that she
betrayed me as a friend
for them being able to get her to go
along with these lies we actually had to
make a whole video explaining this mess
which should tell you just how
stupidly complicated it is everybody is
still
streaming we still don't know who
manipulated who
bob7 has still lost his job and before
you know it
twitch is gonna move on to the next
batch of drama
coming out number seven now is doctor
disrespect
there's a lot of mystery surrounding the
doc's current twitch band but
back in 2019 there was no mistaking the
reason he was
temporarily suspended he did his first
ever irl stream at e3 that year to give
his viewers a tour of what he was up to
at the event
everything was going pretty smoothly
until for some reason he thought it
would be a good idea to stream
in a public bathroom twitch banned him
the very same day for two weeks
he stayed quiet for even longer than
that but when dr disrespect finally
spoke
he did so out of character guy beam the
man behind dr disrespects
mullet tweeted an apology from his
personal account stating
we wanted to capture an adventure
unfortunately
we took that adventure into the wrong
areas unaware of the legality
surrounding it on behalf of the doctor
disrespect brand
i apologize for this
things are getting pretty ugly now at
number six with tifu
versus faze in may 2019
huge twitch streamer tfu hit faze clan
with
two lawsuits in which he claimed they
have been exploiting him with an
oppressive onerous and one-sided
contract
which he wanted to be released from and
so began
a 15-month legal back and forth
we ended up doing no less than eight
videos on this topic
faze countersued and stated they'd only
collected
60 000 of the 20 million they had helped
tfu earn
things got personal too when faze bank
released a whole video addressing the
situation
tfu i called you my family and i got no
heads up i got absolutely no warning of
this this is something that could have
easily been handled offline and if this
was just about making even more money
than you do now and we
could have gotten to that point too dude
like i don't understand
it doesn't make any sense to me and
let's not forget tfu's bizarre video in
the hollywood hills with the hashtag
release the contract show the contract
face
release the contract everybody hashtag
release the
contract release it it was arguably the
first
major employment lawsuit in esports but
after almost a year
and a half of legal mudslinging the two
parties settled
out of court which means we'll never
know what really went down
uncle sam is knocking at the door now
it's the us army's twitch disaster
at number five in an effort to recruit
young
tax savvy members the us army started
streaming on twitch in 2019.
there was outrage at the fact that
viewers as young as 13 years old were
being
targeted often from disadvantaged
backgrounds
on top of that they were also accused of
sharing
fake prize giveaways that literally just
sent whoever clicked on the links to
their army recruitment page
with no further information about the
prize
now some people took it upon themselves
to let the us army know they
weren't welcome on twitch waves of
viewers began to ask the us army
streamers about
u.s war crimes and the chat bans came
quickly after
soon after slasher reported that the u.s
army had paused all social media
activity
including twitch a video about twitch
drama would
not be complete without the juicer
himself and number four entry
is xqc's many many drama moments
there was a time he got twitch band for
stream sniping the time he got banned
for playing a strip connect four game
and the time he got banned for
accidentally showing porn on stream but
even when xqc's behavior doesn't draw a
twitch man
drama is never too far behind a good
example
is when he tormented offline tv's rust
server
aside from killing everyone on site and
being generally pretty toxic
things reached a boiling point when xqc
began accusing
other players of stream sniping he
actually was
she was he went out on the seat and uh
that's just shameless dude
i can't that's just shameless that's so
cringe dude
and it wasn't long before some of the
big names began to get
fed up with xqc's antics i tune in for
one second
into the rust server and
i immediately see xuc's crew just
killing just random people
oh my god if i was a server admin i'd
kick all of them
like that like that and when he did
apologize on twitter for his behavior
the damage had already been done as
streamers left the server behind the
question
on many people's lips was it's xqc
what did you expect no poke yeah
get out talking about move move mob i'm
not really
next up at number three we have a linity
the popular streamer wound up
a lot of people in july 2019 when a clip
was shared of her
allegedly throwing her cat over her
shoulders
while people debated about whether or
not this constituted as animal abuse
someone wrote out an entire twitter
detailing the
many times she allegedly mistreated her
pets
the most notable of those is a clip that
shows her spitting
vodka into her cat's mouth elinity
tweeted a response in which she
apologized for her
lapse in judgment but maintained that
she only dropped the cat
and that the vodka thing was a stupid
thing to do
moving on to number two we have pink
sparkles and the saga
of the worst streamer house in history
in july 2019 pink sparkles moved into a
new
streaming house with other streamers
such as mitch jones and k
bubbles but things quickly went downhill
it started with ping not being impressed
by mitch partying at 4am
[Music]
and then mitch showed a pretty horrific
clip of k-bubbles
letting her dog [ __ ] all over the house
there's a turd right there there's a
turd right there there's a turd right
there
there's turds everywhere somehow things
got even
more insane when their address got
leaked and someone anonymously
wrote to the homeowner letting them know
what was going on
and the group was soon served an
eviction notice
now this was all shared by pink sparkles
in an effort to explain
her side of things but that only
prompted some housemates to claim
she was throwing them under the bus the
group
soon parted ways many claimed the
experiment had
failed but if the purpose of these
streamer houses is to produce content
this one certainly succeeded
and finally at number one we have twitch
vs the people
sometimes the biggest drama on twitch is
the drama twitch causes itself
when twitch banned the use of the word
simp virgin
and incel as insults it got a pretty
strong reaction from the community
what this is so stupid dude
no one identifies as an insole in a
in a positive way anyway like what watch
sip sip sip simpson
and i mean if anything goes wrong at
least it's your channel not mine
twitch started off 2021 by removing the
famous pog champ emote which featured
ryan
goutex gutierrez gutex tweeted out
support for the capitol hill riots that
month
and then shared a video of a woman being
shot and killed during the insurrection
gutek's behavior had been concerning for
quite some time but this seemed to be
the last straw for twitch
they stated that they can't in good
conscience
continue to enable use of the image
while many supported the move
twitch still collectively lost its [ __ ]
and talk about them wait where's
pogchamp
smile wait pog champ got removed
wait what are you talking about paw
champ
did he really wait what
no well guys that was some of the
craziest drama that twitch has to offer
which one of those stood out for you
maybe you love all the drama i mean you
are watching this video
after all don't forget to subscribe on
your way out of the door
thank you so much for watching and i'll
see you all in the next one
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages